so it was crazy because I went into the
office and he was using the whole punch
and I was like you're doing it wrong you
don't use plastic use it on paper he's
stupid
that's the definition of dumb [ __ ] I
mean absolutely excuse me my friends
there's no seats in the comfy O's you
might take that chair between you you
could sit with that yeah you know I like
actually simple sit with you - yeah you
can just like that there we don't care
you could join us
oh yeah sure great why not
yeah right in the middle I guess right
thank you so much
yeah we love when people sitting between
us and sit close to us because that's
what humans need they need a lot of
affection and touching that's what
life's about it's meeting new people
it's totally find that your newspaper
smells like mothballs in my grandma in a
closet and it's totally fine to like
walk our friendship with a big newspaper
china daily newspaper
gee you guys want me to move well I got
no it's no big deal I couldn't sit on
the floor we love it oh my god they got
Logan okay
did you see the title he's great I mean
it's like an old lizard sitting on a
rock in front of the Sun train again
Ellie get a tan or whatever Rachel he
can't he's just gonna get cancer cuz
he's an old lizard from 1973 and there's
like baby blue shirts like he's trying
to copy the sky and be like oh my God
look at me I'm so angelic from from the
heavens because of my big blue shirt and
because this shirt is the same color is
the sky like a bird is totally gonna
show ya talking about it myself are you
know oh yeah sorry
and it's like what are you a children's
book like nobody wants that wedding to
be an adult's book like Game of Thrones
if yet like home like hey family I'm
gonna watch sports if you like try to
show the whole family needs into sports
when really he's watching Nickelodeon
dammit what's wrong with you people you
know what I wasn't gonna say anything
but I knew you were talking about me
you my dear are wearing a baby blue
shirt so am i you're making fun of
somebody for wearing the same color
you're wearing sofa bird shits on me a
bird shits on you and I look you mustard
sweater t-shirt thing you think you look
like Julia Roberts I think you look like
your brother Eric Roberts I didn't want
to say anything but that dumb look of a
new is stupid you are so hot so sexy and
you just love the way your eyebrows
furrow when you get angry like that yeah
this is what Logan and I need a man to
yell at us every now and then you guys
messy what they I don't know well I have
about ten minutes if you want to go in
my van you know oh oh my god what's that
smell whatever we could still go by man